شغلت البحريه الامريكيه في سابقه سفينه
حربيه من ميناء اجنبي يقع في مدينه سيدني
الاستراليه وقال الجيشان الامريكي
والاسترالي ان الخطوه تظهر الالتزام
بتعزيز التنسيق بينهما في المحيط الهادئ
تزامن ذلك واجراء واشنطن تدريبات عسكريه
بمشاركه دول عده كبرت اظهارا للقوه امام
تعزيز الصين نفوذها في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان ذكاء خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاش ثلاثه مسارات مارسائل
المناورات والمناورات المضاده في المحيط
الهادئ وما دلاله الشراكه الاستراتيجيه
بين الولايات المتحده واستراليا وكيف
ينعكس التكامل العسكري الاستراتيجي بينهما
على نفوذ الصين في المياه الدوليه
وكيف ستتعامل الصين مع بناء واشنطن جدارا
جيوسياسيا على سواحلها الجنوبيه والشرقيه
ونشر قطع حربيه ونقل تكنولوجيا الغواصات
النوويه الى جارتها استراليا
وما هو مستقبل الاحداث وحضورها في هذه
المنطقه وهل تتجه بجين لتحالف استراتيجي
اكثر وضوحا مع روسيا في مواجهه اكواس
وغيرها من التفاهمات الامريكيه الاسيويه
[موسيقى]
تكاد تدريبات والمناورات العسكريه تتحول
الى خبر شبهي يومي في المحيط الهادئ على
وقع صراع النفوذ في المنطقه بين
واشنطن تجري الولايات المتحده تدريبات
دوريه مع استراليا تدريبات يشارك في
نسختها الراهنه اكثر من 30 الف جندي ومن
ثلاثه عشره دوله اهم القوات المشاركه قدمت
من فرنسا واليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه
واندونيسيا ونيوزيلندا وبريطانيا والمانيا
التي سجلت حضورها لاول مره
القائد الاسترالي للعمليات المشتركه ليث
نانت
جنرالتون اكد ان سفينه تجسس صينيه رصدت في
اليوم السابق لبدايه التدريبات قباله
سواحل شمال شرق اوستراليا اما وزير الدفاع
الاسترالي ريتشارد مارليس فقد جاء بيانه
اوضح بشان الرسائل من وراء المناورات
وتشغيل سفينه حربيه امريكيه لاول مره في
ميناء اجنبي في سن الاستراليه البيان قال
ان تشغيل سفينه الامريكيه في المياه
الاستراليه يعكس الالتزام المشترك بدعم
النظام القائم على القواعد
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من بيجين فيكتور
جاو رئيس الجمعيه الصينيه للدراسات
الدوليه والدبلوماسيه السابق ومن واشنطن
معنا الدكتور جون عضو مجلس الامن القوميه
سابقا ومعك دكتور جون
سنبدا بالسؤال عن الرسائل ولمن توجه هذه
الرسائل بشكل مباشر من خلال هذه المناورات
بين الولايات المتحده واستراليا بمشاركه
الدول الثلاث عشره التي ذكرناها
هو مستوى من التعاون اعلى بكثير مما
شاهدناه في الماضي فالتعاون بين الولايات
المتحده واستراليا من قبل كان جيدا ولكنه
يشمل الان عدد من الدول بما فيها المانيا
كما تفضلتم وللمره الاولى وبالتالي هناك
مجموعه من المصالح تركز على حريه الملاحه
وحريه التجاره الدوليه اذا
هذا
بوضوح ما يوجه او يحفز هذه التدريبات
واعتقد ان ما سنشهده ليس موجهان مباشره ضد
الصين ولكنه ياتي
رده فعل لما تراه اطول في المنطقه كوجود
صينيين اكثر عدائيه في منطقه المحيط
الهادئ
يعني كيف لا تكون موجهه ضد الصين وهي رده
فعل على تعزيز الصين لنفوذها كيف لا تكون
وجهه ضد الصين
ما هو العامل الذي تغير في السنوات
الاخيره اعتقد ان الجميع يريد الحفاظ على
الوضع الراهن الا وهو وضع مسالم يسمح
للتبادلات التجاريه بطريقه حره وهذا امر
يهم كافه الدول في المنطقه بما فيها الصين
اليابان وكوريا واستراليا وهي تستفيد منه
اذا التصور في هذه الدول مفاده ان الصين
تعزز نفوذها بطريقه اكثر عدائيه بما قد
يهدد قنوات التواصل وهذه المسارات
التجاريه وهذا هو التغيير الذي طرا في
السنوات الاخيره
هل ترى الصين فعلا في هذه المناورات
محاوله امريكيه مع حلفائها تحديدا
استراليا للحفاظ على وضع مسالم للمحيط
الهادئ
شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه اولا اسمحوا لي
ان اؤكد على نقطه في البدايه ان بحر جنوب
الصين هو بحر صيني ومنطقه تايوان والمنطقه
برمتها تعيش سلاما منذ عقود ولا يوجد نزاع
ولا توجد حرب في هذه المنطقه لكن مثل هذه
المناورات الكبيره التي تقودها الولايات
المتحده لن تؤدي الى السلام ربما
الولايات المتحده تريد جلبا نزاعات وحروب
كما فعلت في مناطق اخرى في العالم الى هذه
المنطقه لهذا السبب الامر ينظر اليه
كتهديد ثانيا الامر يظهر متى الاحباط
والهستيريا من جانب المتحده لانه هو من
حيث
المبدا الوراه المتحده
الجميع بانها غير سعيده
باستمرار نمو الصين وتناميها السالميه
وتريد ان تفعل كل ما تستطيع لعرقله نمو
الصين الاقتصادي واقول لكم ان هذه
المحاوله ستبوء بالفشل لان الصين تقف وبكل
قوه دفاعا عن مصالحها وتريد ان تتحدث مع
كل من يريد ان ياتي الى بيتين ليتحدث معها
ومؤخرا راينا مجموعه من كبار المسؤولين
مثل الوزير بلنكن والوزير
والمستشار السابق هند كاسندر والسيد جون
كاري كلهم جاءوا الى الصين اعتقد ان
الطريق الوحيد الحديث عن السلام والتنميه
هو الصحيح عوضا عن التلويح باستخدام القوه
وكانها ستح
كلا الصين ثابته وراسخه وصلبه ولم تتاثر
بمثل هذا التلويق باستخدام القوه وهذا
مضيعه للوقت تماما اذا الصين ترى في هذه
المناورات تهديدا
والولايات المتحده تريد بذلك احتواء الصين
هي
وحلفائها سيدي جون يعني
لو اخذنا هذا الكلام بالاعتبار اضافه الى
مشاركه الولايات المتحده في القمه الاخيره
قمه مع دول شرق اسيا الا تسعى فعلا
الولايات المتحده لمحاصره الصين اكان
عسكريا من خلال
حلفائها ومناوراتها في المحيط الهادئ وحتى
سياسيا من خلال هذا التحالف او بناء هذا
الحلف الجيو سياسي مع دول شرق اسيا ايضا
في مواجهه الصين
ما نشهد في المناطق المحيطه بالصين اساسه
اصلا هو رغبه الدول الموجوده في تلك
المنطقه هي التي تسعى الى تعزيز الامن وهي
التي تبحث عن المزيد من الاستقرار في
المنطقه وعن تعزيز علاقات مع الولايات
المتحده ومع دوله يمكنها ان تؤمن لها نوعا
من الامن اذا هذا ما اختلف في السنوات
الاخيره حيث ان تلك الدول هي التي توجهت
بطلب من الولايات المتحده من اجل تعزيز
علاقتها معها
وبهدفي تعزيزي العلاقه الدفاعيه انا اوافق
الدكتور جاو الراي ولكن من المهم جدا ان
تستمر هذه المحادثات نرى الكثير من
الدبلوماسيين الامريكيين رفعي المستوى
الذين يلتقون النظرائهم الصينيين ولكن
هناك مجال ايضا لدبلوماسيه والحوار لتعميق
المعرفه وتبادلات
السلميه بين الدولتين تلافيا لاي نزاع لن
يكون في مصلحه احد طيب سيد فيكتور جو يعني
هذه النقطه مهمه جدا التي
ذكرها سيد جون بان جيران والدول المحيطه
بالصين هي التي يعني تخشى من الصين
وترى نفسها مهدده من الصين وهي التي سعت
نحو الولايات المتحده من اجل التحالف معها
وبالتالي ليست الولايات المتحده الملامه
بانشاء هذا الحلف الجيو سياسي في مواجهه
الصين
انا اختلف تماما في الوقت المتحده في
السنوات القليله الماضيه هم دائما يقولون
الحلفاء بان ستكون هناك حرب بين الصين
المتحده ويقولون ما نقوم بهذا اختبار
لحاله الحرب والكبار المسؤولين الامريكيين
يتحدثون المره تلو المره الحرب مع الصين
فهم ينظرون الى الصين على اساس انها عدول
هذا سبب
اليابان واستراليا وغيرها هؤلاء هم حلفاء
عسكريون الوطن المتحده فاذا قالت المتحده
الصين ننظر لها كعدو ماذا يمكن هؤلاء ان
يقولوا هم يريدونه ان يبقوا حلفاء
فسينضمون الى قافله وصم الصين بالعدو اذا
اصل واساس هذه المشكله هو رؤيه امريكا
للصين العدو والتهديد والتلويحي بالحرب
يرضى هم يعيشون حاله من الخيال لان الحرب
ليست خيارا بين الولايات المتحده والصين
اذا كانت هناك حرب فستكون حرب يوم القيامه
او الهمر جده والتي
تجعل كلا الطرفان يعاني من جراح قاتله
ومميته ولا هي ليست امرا يتطلع المرء اليه
لذا علامات المتحده عوضا عما تتحدث عنه عن
الحرب طيله الوقت ان تجلس او تتحدث الى
السلام لان الحرب ليست خيارا
وكل هذا وكل المناورات هذه ليست الا مضيعه
للوقت لان استراتيجيتهم اصلا خاطئه عليهم
ان يركزوا على السلام بدلا من الحرب لكن
ليسوا ليسوا هما يقوم بمناورات الصين
وروسيا ايضا تقوم بمناورات يعني الصين
وروسيا لا تضيع وقتا والولايات المتحده
وحلفائها يضيعون وقتا ابقى معي هنا في في
هذه النقطه مشاهدينا مناورات بمناورات
واحلاف
وامن المحيط الهادئ رهين دوامه من استعراض
القوه والتلويح باوراقها كما ذكرنا في
مقابل التدريبات الغربيه تواصل قوات من
البحريه الروسيه والصينيه مناورات مشتركه
في بحر اليابان يجري فيها اطلاق ذخيره حيه
على اهداف بحريه وتحمل التدريبات اسم
التفاعل
التدريبات الروسيه الصينيه شملت محاكاه
لمهام البحث عن غواصات غير معروفه الهويه
ومرافقتها
وابعادها باختصار هنا سيد
يعني ايضا روسيا والصين تقومان
بمناورات لماذا لا يعتبر ذلك ايضا
استعدادا لحرب في الوقت الذي تدخل فيه
روسيا وهي مشغوله اساسا بحرب اوكرانيا
استمعوا الي بكل دقه في الاشهر القليله
الماضيه الولايات المتحده
جعلت قاذفات قنابل استراتيجيه تعود اليها
تحلق في سمايا المنطقه
وارسلت غواصات نوويه الى شبه جزيره
الكوريه
وايضا
تنشر قدرات استراتيجيه وفتاكه بما في ذلك
اسلحه نوويه في المنطقه المجاوره للصين
اما الصين التي لها حدود مشتركه مع اربعه
الاف وخمسمائه كيلومتر من الحدود بيننا
وبين الصين فاذا قمنا نحن وهذا البلد
المجاور بمناورات عسكري هذا امر روتوني
ليس مودع ضد احد ليس دليلا على هستيريا بل
هو عنصر من اجل تع
واستقرار المنطقه لذا فهذا مختلف تماما في
طبيعته عن دبلوماسيه التلويح بالقوه
وقرع الطبول الحرب التي تمارسها الولايات
المتحده ضد الصين ودعوني اضيف كلمه اخرى
قبل ان اتوقف بالنسبه للولايات المتحده ان
تنظر الى الصين كعدو هو خطا استراتيجي في
النتيجه سيخلق تداعيات سلبيه للغايه ضد
الولايات المتحده وست تقع الولايات
المتحده في شر افعالها نتيجه لاخطاء هذه
الصين ليست على دول الوقت المتحده كفوا عن
اعتبار الصين المتحده لو ان الصين اعتبرت
الولايات المتحده عدوا لكان ذلك نهايه
الهيمنه الامريكيه
لك الرد على ذلك فعلا الولايات المتحده
اليست هي من وسمت الصين بالعدو اليست هي
من اعتبرت ان الصين هي التهديد
الاستراتيجي للولايات المتحده وقيم
الولايات المتحده اليست الولايات المتحده
هي التي حشدت حلفاء في مواجهه نمو الصين
اكان الاقتصادي او السياسي او النفوذ في
اكثر من
منطقه في العالم اليست الولايات المتحده
التي تجر المنطقه نحو التوتر والتصعيد
يمكنني ان اقول انني اوافق الدكتور جاو
على نقطه واحده مافادها انه ليس هناك سبب
لمواجهه عسكريه بين دولتين
فهذا لا يصب في مصلحه اي من الدولتين وسوف
لن يجري بطريقه تفيد ايا منهما
وبالتالي العلاقات بين الدولتين لا يمكن
ان تكون علاقات عسكريه
حلقات خصوم عسكريين حين عملت في وزاره
خارجيه وزاره الدفاع اكثر ما سمعته هو
الحديث عن تنافس او منافسه العلاقه مع
الصين ينظر اليها على انها منافسه
استراتيجيه وهي تتخطى مجرد منافسه عسكريه
او علاقه عسكريه هي تشمل التجاره وحقوق
الملكيه الفكريه والقيامه الديمقراطيه
وحقوق الانسان هي متعدده الاوجهه والجوانب
وهي من العناصر الاساسيه للعلاقات في
القرن الحادي والعشرين العلاقات بين الدول
من المهم جدا
المتحده عفوا عفوا للتوضيح سيدي جون
للتوضيح الولايات المتحده ترى
ترى في الصين يعني اقرب الى العدو تهديد
استراتيجي وليس مجرد منافس اقتصادي هذا
هذا الامر واضح حتى بالاستراتيجيات
للولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
فان هذه العلاقه اساسها الدول في المنطقه
هي التي تعرف هذه العلاقه واضح انها هي من
يسعى الى تعزيز الاستعداديه والجهوزيه
العسكريه تريد ان تعزز قدراتها الدفاعيه
والامنيه وتريد ان تتمكن من التعاون مع
دول المجاوره والولايات المتحده في حال
وقع اي اعتداء قامت به الصين لا اعتقد ان
هذا محتمل على المدى القريب ولكن هذا شيء
تاخذه دول المنطقه في الاعتبار
وطوله اهميه اذا العلاقه
سوف تحدد ما هو مستوى هذه المناورات وهذه
التدريبات نحن نعزز مناوراتنا مع كوريا
الجنوبيه هذا العام بصوره اساسيه بسبب
انعدام الاستقرار في شبه الجزيره الكوريه
ولان هذا ما تريده الحكومه في كوريا
الجنوبيه وتطلبه منا وهناك اكثر من نقطه
التوتر ايضا في المنطقه التايوان فضلا عن
موضوع كوريا الشماليه والكثير من نقاط
التوتر والتنافس بين الولايات المتحده
والصين اعود اليك سيد فيكتور
امام ما يتشكل من من حلف بين الولايات
المتحده
وشركائها والذي تمظهر في هذه المناورات
الاخيره ماذا ستفعل الصين مع من ستتحالف
في مواجهه
هذا الحلف الامريكي الاسترالي الغربي
جزيلا تعلمون على وجه
اليقين انه المتحده لديها اكثر من
ثلاثين دوله تدخل فيها ضمن نوع ما من
اشكال التحالف
والنيتو لديه حوالي 30 بلدا اما الصين لم
تدخل في ايه حلف عسكري مع اي بلد اخر يمكن
ان ننظر الى هذه الامور من زاويه ان الصين
لديها ثقه كامله بقدرتها على الدفاع عن
نفسها ومصالحها وسلامه اراضيها وسيادتها
وهي تعتمد اعتمادا كاملا على مصادر قوتها
الذاتيه وليس لدى الصين اي قواعد اجنبيه
في العالم حتى عن قاعده واحده في جيبوتي
في القرن الافريقي لاغراض الدفاع ضد
الارهاب بينما الولايات المتحده لديها
مئات القواعد العسكريه
اذا لصالح الولايات المتحده سيد جاوا هذا
هذا الامر عفوا سيد جاو هذا الامر يلعب
لصالح الولايات المتحده بان التوازن ليس
هناك تكافؤ في القوه بين الولايات المتحده
والصين وليس هناك توازن في في هذه القوات
انا اختلف مع هذا الراي هذا يعني ان الصين
تملك القدره الاكتفاء الذاتي وهي صليبه في
تمسكها بمبادئها وقدرتها على الدفاع عن
سيادتها وسلامه اقليمها بالاعتماد الكلي
على مواردها ومصادر قوتها وليست الصين
بحاجه الاعتماد على اي قوه خارجيه روسيا
حتى روسيا ليست بحاجه لها
روسيا بلد مجاور والصين روسيا ليست
حليفتان بل بلدان
متجاوران وهم ما نتحدث عن
بلدين شهرين ولا تجعلوا من الصين الروسحه
لفين عسكريين لانكم تعرفون على وجه اليقين
انه بين الصين وروسيا
والوقت المتحده اي بلد من هذه البلدان
الثلاثه يواجه الاثنين الاخرين عسكريا
سينتهي الى دمار فلا تدفعوا باتجاه جعل
الصين روسيا
حليفان الاخر معادله سيخسر تماما شكرا ما
نشبت
تكون سعداء لان روسيا ليست عذرا للمقاطعه
حدثنا من بيجين وشكرا للدكتور جون اسعد
مجلس الامن القومي سابقا كان معنا من
واشنطن
انتهت حلقتنا الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]